to the house mission is adopted without
objection the motion to reconsider is
laid upon the
table
that is it that is the historic moment
when the house of representatives
voted to impeach
donald j trump donald john trump for the
second time the falling of the gavel
is the moment at which a house
resolution is passed
that now goes to the senate and the
senate will have to arrange
for a trial by senators on
charges of
of high crimes and misdemeanors of uh
donald trump and i think we can probably
look at the scoreboard
again what we can see is that
10 republicans voted with the democrats
to impeach donald trump
i think there were possib there were
three or four abstainers which may also
be people
who felt that they couldn't vote against
impeachment but didn't want
to go all the way
it would be possible or would have been
possible
for the senate to expedite the trial and
to
come back early tomorrow and start with
that business
but mitch mcconnell who currently
is the majority leader failed to reach
agreement with the
democratic minority leader charles
schumer on that so
the senate will be back on the 19th
that's next tuesday that's the day
before the inauguration but it's
unlikely i think
that they'll get straight down to the
trial particularly since a number of
republicans have said
that things are moving rather too
quickly there we have it the final score
there
uh yay to impeachment 232
representatives nay
197 and
of uh those 232 10 of them
were republican representatives